come on man look we all grew up we've
seen star trek
every kid every year
every single kid every single kid just
wished as they watched star trek that
they could be
in the borg so resistance is futile yes
i'm kidding nobody wanted to be the borg
the board was the nightmare
that's right so i'm a big star trek fan
i own it people make fun of me
whatever they already do that so um
i'm a big next generation fan and
jean-luc picard is the ultimate
stoic in leadership i have a whole stick
on this we can explore if you want
but jean-luc ricardo is all about duty
and responsibility and he never told a
lie
and he was all about the broader mission
so gene roddenberry
um was the creator of the idea of star
trek
who always was trying to say that we
need like the ideal is a post-commercial
society
you didn't own anything there was no
currency and
basically in the federation right in the
federation right well
on the particular mission right so the
the idea of the starship enterprise
actually earth let me even correct that
on earth in the star trek narrative
they had gotten rid of private property
they have gotten rid of commerce i don't
think that's true okay
you could you could correct me there's
there's i think the issue is
the writers wanted to create that ideal
of a future with no property
but that broke the motive uh function of
of humanity and so what ends up
happening is you see depictions of
beachfront properties
and you see in deep space nine for
instance uh
um latinum was heavily traded i
understand deep space nine was
working with different uh you know
different civilizations were coming and
going
but even in uh the next generation
federation credits are used to exchange
between the federation and other
civilizations
so currency existed within the
federation
sure they had some kind of the that that
could be right
the point i'm making though is
roddenberry created this idea that you
can have what you want when you wanted
right
food will appear as you want it you can
go in the holodeck but i think he
actually make
he makes the best point for flawed human
nature which is
cons against the anti-commercial thought
of rousseau
which is that we do bad things because
of our society because we always want
things and it's
that's what gives us gives us our greed
and if that would be the if that
actually was true there'd be no drama in
star trek
instead they still have romantic
relationships they still
lie they still cheat they still steal
the point i'm getting at which is a
contrarian point
is that in gene roddenberry to try to
create this idea of a futuristic utopia
he actually says even if we get rid of
all the needs wants and interests the
individual
you're still going to have tension and
drama amongst fellow human beings
or human beings and other species i love
too the uh the left likes to say star
trek is communism well
it's not it's literally not it's it's an
idealized poster
techno communism it's not it's it's
idealized post-scarcity classical
liberalism
there there there are people in charge
there's military hierarchy
yeah huge hierarchy there's admiral
picard in the new picard series
there there there there are choices
people can make places they can go
it's not that everything is necessarily
free if you actually it may be because
different writers wrote different things
and different episodes have different
elements
but very much so it is not communist
there are things of value there are
artifacts
picard owns a winery but it's not total
post scarcity because they run the
energy the enterprise off of what
dilithium crystals
but can they 3d print dilithium in there
so that's right it's post scarcity in
terms of basic human needs
but very much right there are there are
rarities there
picard's an archaeologist there are rare
artifacts that he wants
he's gifted an artifact in one episode
and he's like i can't believe this is
given to me wow it's
you can't get these you can't make them
it's like an old artifact from an
ancient civilization
very much so scarcity and rarities and
value
exists so reduce scarcity food scarcity
and shelter
for for human for human sustenance right
all of that scarcity
disappeared in that there was no longer
a factor the writers in order to make
the show
function cross continuity with the other
episode other other series
money needed to exist because it was
post scarcity platinum
food and shelter was post scarcity but
only if you had dilithium
because if you didn't have the energy
earth earth was fine but earth earth
must have been running also off of the
lithium ions
that lithium crystals are for the warp
core reactors for for general purpose
they had
renewable energy retaining energy from
the vacuum and you make a really good
point though
is that the three words that is most
repeated by picard would make him closer
to marcus aurelius than to
you know an egalitarian leader which is
make it so yeah i mean
that is the most clear way that you can
command anyone not like
hey do you think this is a good idea
instead of make it so the
the idea of whenever you talk to a
communist and say that's not real
communism right
what what is real communism they say it
is everyone living equally in full
ownership blah blah blah
blah blah blah blah yeah but but when
when you bring up dictatorship they say
that's that's the
that's the deviation communism isn't
supposed to have the people who control
everything and are the wealthy elites
the card has his own ready room on the
bridge what gives him this
luxury i think i think it was nicholas
gomez davila that said every equal
society is divided into two parts
yeah right like there's always got to be
somebody making everybody else equal
yeah and uh there was there was a great
episode
where q he's this omnipotent entity not
that cute
no i don't i don't think so no this is
this is just so how everyone knows q is
like a divine
figure in star trek he's he's part of
the continuum of ascended
wow so it's not the sep is it the 17th
letter i think it's the same yes yes but
anyway
picard gets the uh oh cue it's him
causing other problems uh picard gets
the opportunity to go back and save his
heart
because he said if i was just not brash
in my youth i never would have lost my
heart getting stabbed in a bar fight
he's a mechanical he's a mechanical
heart and so he goes back changes
history
and then when he returns the present
he's a lowly science officer
a low low ranking officer of some sort
and when he goes and he talks to
riker he says do i have what it takes to
be leadership
riker says you've always been scared to
take the risk necessary
to to do what needed to be done so
honestly no i don't think you'll ever
make it
and then picard goes enough cue send me
back i get it
the point was you had to earn something
you were told if you didn't work hard
enough and do what you had to do you
wouldn't earn it and you weren't good
enough
and that's what michael malus says is
the big question that i think is
mel says this um what determines whether
someone is on the right or the left
have you ever heard him ask this no let
me ask you the question do you think
that some people are better than others
of course well do i think they're better
at things than others or do they have
more inherent worth than others
i just said do you think some people are
better than others plain and simple
yeah there's a couple different ways to
interpret this but yes generally i think
there's a hierarchy of
it it's a broad question it could mean a
lot of things michael mentioned that on
the left then the
leftists will say no of course not and
some or they'll hemen haw and say well i
mean
but people on the on the new right will
just be like yeah of course the only
the only asterisk i would put is that
one human being at birth does not have
an inherent value over another right
right
but if you were to if you were to say
are some people better than others
there's there's a there's a bunch of
reasons why the answer is yes
some people are better at basketball
than others of course some people are
better at
math than others yeah but they could be
worse at the same
at something as well exactly so like
absolutely are they better yes yes
and are they worse yes so the point is
it's not an incomplete question it's
just a broad question
i didn't say in every respect i didn't
say are some people better than
others in every single if you're better
at basketball than another person but
worse at math then
is there like a total of worseness so
you're not better even though you are
some you're better than them you you you
don't need to add qualifiers to the
statement that
if i say are some people better than
others we're not getting specific
the fact the matter is everyone is
better than everyone else for some
reason or other reason
the point is yes quite simply uh
charlie's better taking notes than i am
i don't even take notes
he's great at it thank you yeah
and this goes back to the idea what he's
really getting at is do you think
there's a hierarchy
of existence and we as conservatives do
we think some things are more beautiful
than others objectively more beautiful
we think that some things are more
desirable and you know
better for society um they think that
it's all just kind of a
subjective exploration who's to say that
that's better than that you're making me
think of the borg
like is is the borg did human okay in
the history of star trek there was a war
right world war
iii happened and then this great
federation came out of that
after sort of i mean i mean long after
there's a lot that happened there was a
big war
there was a period where authoritarian
governments ruled by
drugging their soul their police
officers into being high all the time
so there's a lot to go okay that
happened in nazi germany and uh you know
so what happens is
uh zephyr zephyr and cockroam copper he
invented the warp drive
uh yeah and it was like a fairly low uh
power low class operation basically
and then the vulcans took notice and
then said oh we better talk to these you
know
fellas we could talk about the vulcans
for a while oh yeah do humans evolve at
some point into or build an ai that then
becomes the board that's very
historicist of you
to believe that human beings are always
on a pathway to the
ubermensch eventually we will matt we
will eventually become the superman
i reject such you have not german
philosophy
you have not seen i haven't seen picard
so uh spoilers for those that haven't
seen picard so is this not like a
paramount login or some crazy thing
see i refuse i reject the premise so uh
i don't wanna watch it cause i was
really worried i was like i know what
they're gonna do and actually
actually was pretty good and it's very
different from the next generation but
it's basically fan service for the fans
of tng where
everybody makes an appearance not
everybody but uh uh brett spiner's in it
and you're like how does he do that he
actually plays data and i was surprised
because he's old and data is an android
but anyway i digress spoiler alerts for
everybody who watched um
or who hasn't watched so in in the show
in nemesis which is one of the i think
was a nemesis the last movie
the last star trek i never saw nemesis
the the last tng movie i think was
nemesis
data sacrifices himself to save picard
the storyline of picard is that someone
was able to take the positronic neurons
from i think
um what was what was the stupid data
called
there was lore and then there was b or
whatever i can remember the name
testing my star trek trivia so they
start making new
much much better synthetic beings and
that's basically the premise that
yes a superior humanoid with
with with synthetics that eats drinks
and lives but can calculate like data is
created
and it's a threat to human to to to
biological existence
and that's the board no oh it's just a
superior synthetic
it is it is like a human it's the super
powers yeah right right right right
right
right
right
right
right
right right right right right right right the
superman
like in like in star trek data can
calculate and they'll be like what's 57
trillion
times you know 47.369 and he's like the
answer to that is
so these new synthetics are super strong
super fast can do all the calculations
are they carbon based can they give
birth
uh i don't think so but they
easily self-replicate that's the kind of
the point i guess self-replication and
so there's a group of romulans that are
like
this new uh a life form is a threat to
the existence of us
the old life forms and the borg are
different the borg are biological that
incorporate mechanics mechanical parts
into their structure
and then eventually connected their
brains on what what i would consider to
be like
um a a an advanced form of twitter
where all their thoughts are heard in
rapid succession and then it forms a
unifying
collective mind are we evil is this
what's happening as humans are splitting
so this is an interesting
question which is that some would say
yes i mean
if you if you play out darwin and hegel
uh they would believe that human
evolution is ever progressing
that that if you look at the historicist
view of the world which is replicated in
this narrative that you talked about
they think that human nature will will
get better and then eventually
we will reach that ultimate level of the
superman
i reject that premise obviously that's
categorically it's it's
it's just wrong i think nature is the
norm i think that
we we are such minuscule
tiny frat pieces of this universe that
the idea of humans would ascend to some
you know yeah without resistance you
like a tree without wind will fall over
and die
you need resistance to grow so i would
imagine as we evolve and become stronger
we're going to seek
new resistance to continue to grow
evolution is not linear
that what what pressure is being exerted
upon humans to make them smarter
stronger for gravity
nothing nothing in fact evolutionary
pressure right now is making humans
stupider and weaker yeah it's not it's
not even necessarily devolution
it's just evolution mike judge said it
best those who procreate
the most are being rewarded by nature
like some because some people are
are building critical thinking skills it
seems like some people are learning
empathy and and
but that's giving psychic power for all
i know to understand evolution you need
to ask
who are procreating the most and why
and you will then you can make
predictions about what's going to happen
the next several generations
there is nothing to suggest that we are
being forced to be smarter stronger and
faster
what what evolutionary pressure would
result in that like uh of a bunch of
aliens came and started hunting and
killing humans the fastest smartest and
strongest humans would survive the
extinction event
have a bunch of babies and the babies
would be much stronger that would be an
evolutionary event
that's not happening right now we're
gorging well i mean actually maybe it is
a lot of dumb people gorging on fast
food and trash and not exercising and
and and decaying in their you know in
their homes and their lounge chairs or
believing that because the earth is
melting they're not going to have kids
at all so the one thing mike judge
missed
is that something we absolutely do see
is that conservatives have more kids
than liberals
and today liberals are even less likely
to have kids
so one thing i've brought up in the past
pew research shows that gen z is
slightly more conservative than
millennials but only by a tiny tiny
amount and only in some areas meaning
they're very much like millennials
slightly more conservative
a lot of people on the right seem to
think that means the right is winning
the culture war
you're not winning the culture war
you're winning the breeding war in the
early 2000s a report was done several
reports showing that liberals on average
were having about 1.7 kids
and conservatives were having 2.02 kids
which meant
in 20 years or in 18 years from that
study
there would be a bunch of voting people
and slightly more conservative
than liberal if that trend continues the
future
absolutely will be religious
conservative maybe not christian maybe
it'll be muslim but
oh that's assuming that uh conservative
parents will have conservative children
but as we're talking about ben stewart
technology kind of hijacks and leaps
evolution so like
a a child of a conservative can go on
the internet and have their evolution
shifted
and become a new you know have noticed
the internet it's also our public
schools you know
right to go back to the crt discussion
just because we win this battle on crt
doesn't mean
we aren't sending our children to the
schools with run by people who thought
crt was a wonderful idea so so that is
i don't think necessarily changes the
equation because some conservative
children
can be indoctrinated and turn to the
left then they're still less likely to
have kids after the fact
so it will effectively have a pull
factor on conservative children but the
end result is always going to be
slightly more conservatives existing
because they're having more kids
so you think it's the uh the uh the
state of mind that is
is resulting in less children i
understand that well i mean they the
aoc i think it was she said i'm scared
to have a kid because of climate change
the there was an article that came out
recently saying having a child is the
most destructive thing you can
do conservatives are like i don't care
about that i'm gonna have kids
yeah and they do should have lots of
kids
yes yeah it's a moral good yes
and and uh uh one of my favorite stories
in terms of the scientific debates is
always about the great
horse manure crisis of new york are you
familiar with this
no before the invention of the
automobile there was a great fear that
as new york expanded
and horses were used to move goods in
and out the
city streets would be just covered in
horse crap everywhere
because well more more city means more
horses what would they do about it they
never had an answer
they never needed one the automobile was
was invented
and the horse was phased out and it
didn't occur so what we need to make
sure of
i i'm i i'm scared of the left for one
reason
i love star trek i'd love to have a star
trek future the left are luddites
they may not they may claim to not be
but their world view is inherently that
we will never improve technology
and we must stop what we're doing right
now
to preserve existence as it is or revert
to some
lesser state you know like more attuned
with
um i don't want to say to with nature
because it's the you will own nothing
and you will be happy right
they're very much like climate change
means we don't have these things
but my world view is very optimistic in
terms of our ability to tap into
technologies that have always found
ways to help save humanity and adapt and
i don't believe we've reached the apex
of technology
you know the famous patent officer
whatever his name was back in the 1899
he was like
everything that can be invented has been
invented he said that because he was
getting such
stupid patents he was like this is
insane
you can't invent anything and then some
dude walks out and goes yo
charged electromagnetic spectrum boomed
what happens if we like in the next five
years breakthrough eureka eureka
some dude at cern runs out and throws
the papers in the air and discovers
anti-gravity
then all of a sudden we're colonizing
every single planet we can find i mean
think about the fact that they
discovered electric i don't know how
long it was between electricity and the
atomic bomb but it really was not that
long period bro bro bro the discovery of
the invention of flight and going to the
moon was a few decades
you're more optimistic than i am i um
i think the left is divided in two
categories the type of leftist you're
describing is not the leftist in charge
the left and
the person in charge right now is
embracing technological innovation and
giving more and more power to a smaller
group of scientists that know what
they're doing yeah
it's interesting you mentioned the
luddites this is a hard argument to make
but there's a lot more nuance to the
luddites than actually people realize
they had their livelihood being
destroyed and they were very worried
about technological innovation
we use that as a pejorative and that's
probably right but to be honest i could
see myself like smashing my phone in the
next five years i think that these
little smooth screens are doing awful
things for humanity
so when i went on my honeymoon really
quick with my wife um in the caribbean
the most beautiful sunsets you could
imagine to my right was a whole family
looking down at their screens at the
moment of the sunset to my left was a
family looking at their screens i
thought to myself
there's something deeply unhealthy about
this and so
you could be right we might be entering
into this wonderful phase of
where technology will improve our life
my fear
to just disagree a little bit is that i
think technology is currently
controlling us
yeah i don't see that you're going to
change how extreme were the luddites
like did they
say no irrigation that's a good question
i mean again i don't
i use i actually read a book about the
many years ago um
tim might actually know it better than
me i wouldn't i wouldn't know because
like the technology controlling is like
irrigation is a technology but it
without it
it's a methodology not a technology well
it's also a form of tech it's a map
i mean an axe is a piece of technology
it's a technology it is but that's
that's a physical object oh
you can't you can't irrigate without
it's it's like the evolution of
technology what you do with technology
is also technology
sure so you need to build tools which
are technology to carve dirt which is a
technology i mean you can patent methods
right
yeah yeah i think the danger of this new
type of
technology that we're coming into is i
don't think we quite can understand what
it does
to the human being i uh we we just we
mentioned it with ben stewart it is a
bunch of humans who don't realize
they're creating some powerful new kind
of entity
and we're mindlessly building it we're
teaching it the recaptcha stuff that's
all just programming it to see and think
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members
only content segments you can't get
anywhere else go to timcast.com become a
member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you